hypothèque épicerie essence la vie à
coûter cher en 2022 je peux dire que oui
je m'inquiète on vient d'avoir un petit
bébé il
y a c'est vrai que en ce moment on est
obligé de fille se fixer un budget un
petit peu pour les dépenses qui sont un
petit peu moins utiles
les indicateurs sont au rouge nombreux
sont ceux qui font d'arriver à joindre
les deux bouts se tourne vers des
syndics de faillite depuis avril on voit
vraiment une hausse des dossiers
d'insalvabilité et on voit que les gens
commencent à avoir de plus en plus de
difficultés à respecter leur engagement
financier entre les mois de novembre
2021 et 2022 le nombre de dossiers d'un
solvabilité a augmenté de 9,5% par
rapport à la même période l'année
précédente c'est ce que rapporte le
Bureau du surintendant des faillite et
c'est aussi ce que constate Sophie des
hôtels sur le terrain même si
l'inflation peut ralentir dans les
prochains mois les prix des biens et
services essentiels auquel on a besoin
vont rester élevés de la l'importance
rappelle-t-elle d'établir un budget
annuel en fait l'importance du budget
c'est d'avoir un budget réaliste un vrai
budget et selon notre réalité financière
à nous on a toujours fait un budget
c'est à bien important puis là il va
avoir des grosses modifications
le mois de janvier est toujours occupé
chez option consommateur qui offre le
service de consultation budgétaire
gratuitement mais Johan Leblanc remarque
que la clientèle change il y a de plus
en plus de gens qui ne sont pas dans des
classes défavorisées qui font appel à
notre service et quel que soit sa
situation financière le pire ennemi du
budget il déni c'est facile de se
tourner vers le crédit là si on utilise
le crédit on utilise le crédit
nécessairement un moment donné la
réalité va nous rattraper d'ailleurs les
Canadiens comptent de plus en plus sur
leur carte de crédit c'est ce que révélé
qui fac ce Canada en décembre dernier
l'endettement moyen des consommateurs et
de plus de 21000 dollars ici qui me
permettra au Canada Montréal